remember a few years ago when we all
discovered that Mitt Romney had an alter
ego Senator Romney we learned went by a
pseudonym
Pierre delecto and as Pierre delecto
Romney liked and replied to tweets from
journalists and from some of his
colleagues in Congress okay
Well turns out there's another
politician in Washington with a gnome de
plume this time it's President Biden
whose pseudonym is Robert L Peters and
as Robert L Peters President Biden
emailed Hunter Biden's crooked business
associates and scheduled secret phone
calls with the president of Ukraine
while running U.S policy on the Eastern
European nation
a little bit different
very different uses of pseudonyms the
house committee on oversight and
accountability has uncovered Biden's
secret identity which appears to have
been a little bit more focused and a
little bit more lucrative than Mitt
Romney's silly burner account the
committee is actually uncovered that
Biden used multiple pseudonymous
accounts to secretly conduct business
with his son and foreign powers while he
was vice president those other
pseudonyms include Robin Ware jrb Ware
and who knows how many others this fact
might explain why Joe Biden struggles
these days to remember his own name he
has so many of them it's difficult to
keep track also might explain why Joe
Biden managed to forget and deny all of
the times that we now know he heard
about participated in and apparently
profited immensely from all those
crooked business deals
it wasn't him after all it was Robert L
Peters
but something tells me despite the
committee's request for more records
that the executive agencies are going to
continue to Stonewall they're not going
to go after Joe Biden or Robert Peters
or Robin Ware or any other Biden Persona
they're not going to go after the
current president for being a crook
they're too busy Prosecuting the former
president for opposing him right now go
to helixsleep.com Knowles with
everything going on in the world right
now you could really use a good night's
sleep that is why you need to check out
Helix mattress Helix has harnessed years
of extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience they just launched their new
Helix Elite the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for years now I absolutely
love it night after night I sleep like a
sweet delicate little child I want the
same for you elix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress why
would you buy a mattress made for
someone else get out of my mattress I'm
a married man go to helixsleep.com
Knowles take their two-minute sleep quiz
to find the perfect mattress for your
body and sleep type their flexible
payment plans make it so that a great
night's sleep is never far away he likes
his own offering twenty percent off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners hurry over to
helixsleep.com Knowles with Helix better
sleep starts
now
hello Michael big fan I just watched
your interview with Tracy Shannon and
while I can't help but feel terrible for
what happened to her and her children
there were a couple things in there that
really did not sit right with me
Tracy refers to being asked by her
husband to do some unusual things in the
bedroom as quote sexual abuse and
coercion to me this is an extremely
grave false accusation the smacks of the
metoo movement and I was hoping you
would push back on this claim a little
bit more
conservative movement I hope we can
distinguish going forward between a
false belief that up ends your entire
life and causes you to not be able to
fulfill your duties to your children and
a bizarre sexual fetish that is kept
relatively within its proper place
inside the bedroom this obviously was
not kept to the bedroom but speaking as
a Catholic who himself struggles with
some pretty severe fetishism I'm very
thankful that my own is not the kind
that will compel me to grievously hurt
others or to upend my own life but there
but for the grace of God go I
I know your advice to me might be simply
knock it off and be normal but as you
know this is much easier said than done
I hope that God willing if I ever were
to get married and gathered the courage
to explain my desires to my wife and to
open up to her about them that she would
be receptive or at least understanding
and patient with me not threaten me with
divorce or accuse me of something
tantamount to rape
like Tracy Shannon did am I being too
harsh on her here please let me know
your thoughts Michael thanks you are you
are being too harsh and it's a very good
question but
you but you're wrong and and
you're wrong in the way that unmarried
guys are wrong because you're saying
look I've got all these bizarre sexual
desires and I just hope that my wife
accommodates them someday
that is not the Catholic view of sex
the Catholic view of sex is that sex has
a purpose okay and the purpose is not
just to indulge whatever fantasies you
have even if you say Well they're not
violent fantasies they're just some
other kind of fantasy right even that
not a great idea the other the other
reason you're wrong here is because you
are viewing desire at in in the way that
Freud might view desire which is that
you got to blow off a little steam and
if you don't indulge some of these
desires then they're going to totally
warp your mind and go go out of control
that's very different from the
Aristotelian view of desire which is
that it's a habit and so you cultivate
habits and the more you indulge say
these sexual fetishes and desires that
you have that's not going to alleviate
those desires it's going to exacerbate
them it's going to make it worse
actually so the best thing that you can
do is try to Tamp them down a little bit
and obviously in a way that is prudent
uh you want to try to turn your desire
it's a fallen world and we're subject to
concupiscence so it's from probably not
going to totally work but you should try
to turn your desire toward that which is
properly ordered and and you will find
this is not just a sex thing this is
true of all disorder desires you will
find that those disorder disorder
desires Abate at least to some degree uh
if as you say you struggle with these
desires now I don't know I'm not
accusing you of looking at pornography
or anything like that or even
fantasizing but don't forget even the
willful entertainment of of disordered
and uh impure and unchaste thoughts and
desires even that is a sin if you do it
willfully and so you should really work
on that because the basic reason is
because sex is not about just you and
fulfilling your pleasure sex is about
the other person your spouse one hopes
and about fully giving of yourself to
the other person not merely you know
titillating yourself and doing that in
such a way that the love between you two
becomes so real that it creates another
person okay
next question yeah to put a button on
hello Michael hold on pause that
question to put a button on them
uh no
no husband or wife has the right to
the Indulgence of of some disordered
sexual desire by his spouse or her
husband uh
for the purpose of of pure pleasure I
mean that that's a very modern view of
sex it's not a not a Christian view of
sex next question
hello Michael this is Brian coming to
you from a village named after a word
derived from the Native American
language meaning mud turtle you
mentioned in the past you would like to
have a deeper cigar discussion on your
program I do need your cigar expertise
what is your protocol after you have
enjoyed a fine cigar in a delicious
beverage and you want to have some
romance with sweet little lease and you
go up to her and she says Mark get away
our breath my question to you is when I
would like to get fresh with the bride
of my youth after enjoying a Monte
Cristo white series and a delicious
beverage what can I do to prevent from
hearing Brian get me with that it's
filthy cigar breath
I appreciate all you do continue being
Delight anytime you're blowing through
the windy city let me know we can have a
chat over Monte Cristo take care bye
a beautifully stated question
you have the cigar afterward
that's that's the real answer you know
uh you're the head of your household
you call the shots ultimately
but Prudence is an important we keep
Prudence keeps coming up today Prudence
is an important virtue and The Prudent
thing to do is
save the cigar for the end of the night
boy what a great clip that was now make
sure you ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles show we'll see you next
time